les États-Unis ne sont prêtes à faire
face au changement climatique l'homme a
consacré sa vie à la mer d'abord comme
pêcheur commercial de saumon pendant
près de 40 ans mais surtout comme
militant écologiste pas besoin de lui
rappeler que l'Alaska se réchauffe de 2
à 4 fois plus vite que le reste du pays
le réchauffement climatique il l'a vu
dans l'eau et sur la terre ferme
[Musique]
de la pêche l'homme de 64 ans est
désormais guide d'aventure à Romain on
lui doit l'adoption du tout premier plan
d'action climatique municipale en Alaska
mais aujourd'hui force et d'admettre que
ce genre d'initiative locale ne sera pas
suffisante
[Musique]
climatique passe aussi entre autres par
la protection du saumon le poisson et
non seulement un moteur économique
crucial il est aussi un symbole
identitaire fort et omniprésent
le saumon est au cœur de la vie en
Alaska dissous
rassembleur dans une époque profondément
marquée par la division directrice
scientifique de l'organisme de
conservation et l'étudie des populations
de ce monde depuis plus de 20 ans
l'espèce résiliente mais elle en demeure
pas moins sensible au changement
climatique l'accélération du
réchauffement menace aujourd'hui la
reproduction du poisson le plus célèbre
de l'État
surpreneur que le changement climatique
soit devenu un enjeu électorale dans cet
état où le contact avec la nature et
constant
le candidat au Congrès d'État se décrit
d'abord et avant tout comme pêcheur
plutôt que de choisir le camp démocrate
ou républicain il se présente comme
indépendant la seule façon selon lui de
vraiment faire avancer les dossiers
importants comme la question climatique
au cœur de sa campagne
[Musique]
les conséquences du réchauffement sont
connues un Homé on s'est habitués années
après année avoir fondre le glacier
growing mais l'Alaska a peut-être vécu
dans les dernières semaines un des chocs
les plus brutaux c'est Kia devraient
normalement être en mer mais la chute
considérable des populations de Krabes
notamment à cause du réchauffement de la
mer a forcé l'Alaska Annuler pour la
première fois cette très lucrative
partout dans l'état croit Louis Flora
subir de plus en plus le réchauffement
l’état demeure un bastion conservateur
dans la petite ville de weatherlin fief
de Sarah pilding qui tente un retour en
politique les changements climatiques
peuvent rapidement être balayés sous le
tapis par certains électeurs
[Musique]
souhaitent-ils l'été a commencé à
changer à interridge plus grande ville
de l'Alaska les rappels de l'urgence
climatique sont bien visibles comme
cette murale qui illustre à quel point
la ville s'est réchauffée depuis 100 ans
impossible d'ignorer l'enjeu s'explique
peut-être que pour la première fois en
50 ans les électeurs de l'étang choisi
une démocratie en nous dernier lors
d'une élection spéciale pour les
représenter au Congrès
occupe le seul siège de l'État la
Chambre des Représentants et tente
maintenant d'obtenir un mandat complet
de deux ans ça récente victoire
constitue une source d'inspiration pour
l'Alaska Center un groupe de pression
progressiste qui se perférez lire à tous
les niveaux des politiciens champion du
climat comme Mary
pelletolase
les candidats en Alaska peuvent de plus
en plus difficilement liés les impacts
du réchauffement souligne du numeric
Strikers
conservateurs ont commencé à en parler
sink ici la question la thématique est
devenue de moins en moins partisan entre
démocrate et républicain
la cause environnementale a beau gagner
des appuis la réponse à l'urgence est
loin d'être suffisante les échéanciers
climatiques et électoraux n'auront
jamais été aussi peu compatibles
croissant
pour réussir le coup de barre nécessaire
une lutte d'ampleur historique s'impose
estime Allen Parks
[Musique]
for Change justice match
habitué aux intempéries la tempête
climatique en cours et celle qui les
ferait de plus parce qu'il ne sait pas
quand et comment elle va finir